he'll take four friends who buy a Lambo
and be like put your hand on this Lambo
first person a last person to have their
hand on this Lambo keeps the Lambo he'll
take four friends who buy a Lambo and be
like put your hand on this Lambo first
person a last person to have their hand
at this Lambo keeps the Lambo have you
seen this guy mr. beast do you know that
is love mr. Bies so if you don't know
who mr. beast is he's this youtuber
who's grown like crazy in the last like
18 months really new he's like a new guy
but he's blown past I don't know how
many subscribers but maybe tens of
millions of subscribers now and his
whole thing is he's just like it just
gives away money to people well like he
does challenges but like typically he'll
give away cars so for example he goes to
a used car dealership and he buys ten
cars which each car is probably five or
ten thousand dollars right maybe he's in
40 or 50 grand on this thing and people
come to buy the car and the and he acts
like the salesman and the lady will be
like alright this car looks good and he
goes ok here and he gives her the keys
he goes no it's yours right
and they film it and this the reaction
it's kind of like that like it has a
feel-good element to it cuz you see
people who are like no way like what
it's guilty he'll go to a restaurant and
leave a two thousand dollar tip on a ten
dollar bill and they're like people
break down crying and then sometimes
it's funny where he'll be like he'll
take four friends who buy a Lambo and be
like put your hand on this Lambo first
person last person to have their hands
on this Lambo keeps the Lambo and they
just for two days straight they just
have their hand on this thing they're
passing out and they you know he may he
turns onto YouTube content and he's
brilliant because he gets brands to pay
for the whole thing so this one brand
quit are quit or quit it's not the
toothbrush it's like this like stickers
trading cards thing on online at least
quid quid has given this guy you know
they'll just put up the 50k he does the
challenge he spouts out quid and they're
happy for it because their videos are
getting like millions of views and so
it's way better branded content than
usual and so he basically took brand
money and parlayed it into being like
huge which is pretty crazy yeah and he
even do a thing where he raised a
hundred million twenty million dollars
for trees shrimp plant a tree and the
founder of Shopify Game one hundred or
sorry a million
Ilan gave a million yeah and he raised
20 million dollars in two weeks yeah and
I have a friend who talked him on the
phone the other day to do a campaign and
he was like what friend Jason
said Jason Hitchcock shoutout to Jason
so he was like you know talking to him
and I when he can't phone he's like yeah
I talked to mr. B's really cool like
talk to his agent or whatever and he
described he's like you know one weird
thing happens which is didn't plan for
this you know sort of success you get
the success but the YouTube game is such
that you kind of need to top yourself
every time probably getting exact and so
he's like dude the stress of like okay
we gave away a Lambo through this like
crazy thing next week what do I do
like okay it's just this constant bar or
a sink which is really tough so when we
first launched our company I get a phone
call from Elizabeth Murdock you know who
Elizabeth Murdoch is Rupert Murdoch's
daughter yeah okay just a big shot and
she was like hey you guys want to do
these videos I'm launching this new
thing and I need video content and I was
like no that's not what we're trying to
do but let's say friends and shoot the
[__] and she was okay well I'll find
someone else so she finds someone else
to do it and they started a YouTube
channel and that YouTube channel is now
called yes theory I've heard of yes they
heard of it yeah they got 5 or 6 million
subscribers and I've become friends with
them over the years and they have a I
mean they're like famous so like legit
famous I don't I have no idea if it's a
good business but I bet you they make
they could each pay themselves a million
dollars a year so pretty good for young
people
pretty good for anyone and each week
they're having to do crazy and crazy
[__] and they've had to do this for
three years now every video is like I
went to the most remote island in the
world right myself and it's three guys
now and they're like taking turns over
doing crazy [__] like it's the crazy
stuff was like I asked my uber driver if
she wants to go to Paris and we went
straight to Paris and went there and now
they're like doing variations of that
it's like oh my god it's like jackass if
Stevo and the Jackass crew had YouTube
and like they would have to do this
every week like we were just lucky that
they were lucky that the cadence was
like you know seasons of TV or a movie
because when it's weekly it's just
insane which is why Casey nice tat
Logan Paul Jake Paul all these guys
eventually peace you know they do this
daily grind for so long but they burn
out like the content burn out is crazy
for sure it's not gonna happen to us
though well it's not gonna happen to us
we just sit and do nothing I don't like
having to get on a plane and like or
like Logan Paul you gotta like yell at
someone or like go break up with a
girlfriend every week you're gonna go
back someone
[Music]